ON THE LINE.
THAT IS THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME TO DEBATE THIS IS
CONSERVATIVE AUTHOR AND
FILMMAKER AND ETHAN BIERMAN,
HOST OF LEFTIST NEWS.
IT DOES SAY SEEM LIKE EVERY WEE
LIBERALS PROVE A DIFFERENT
STEREOTYPE CORRECT.
WE JUST LAID OUT A IF YOU HAVE
THEM IN THE ANGLE, BUT WE COULD
DO AN ENTIRE HOUR ON THIS.
ON.
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE OF GUNS
, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> WELL, I THINK THAT THIS
VINDICATES KIND OF WHAT THE NRA
HAS BEEN WARNING FROM THE OUTSET
.
AT FIRST, FOR MANY YEARS I
THOUGHT THE NRA WAS KIND OF
USING THE SLIPPERY SLOPE
ARGUMENT THAT WAS THAT
ESSENTIALLY THAT ONCE YOU START
OUT LYING ONE TYPE OF WEAPON,
YOU WILL THEN SLOWLY PROCEED TO
OUTLINE THE NEXT TYPE AND THEN
IT BECOMES KIND OF A
COMPREHENSIVE CONFISCATION.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THIS ISN'
EVEN A SLIPPERY SLOPE, IT NOW
APPEARS LIKE THERE'S A WHOLE
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT FROM THE
OUTSET WANT A COMPREHENSIVE BAN
AND THESE MASS SHOOTINGS ARE
MAKING THEM COME OUT OF THE
CLASSIC AND BE MORE AND MORE
FRANK AND CANDID ABOUT WHAT
THEIR REAL AGENDA IS.
IT NEVER WAS A KIND OF TARGETED
OR NARROWLY TARO TAILORED WHILE
IT IS ULTIMATELY AN ALL-OUT
ASSAULT ON THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
LET'S REMEMBER THE SECOND
AMENDMENT IS NO LESS IMPORTANT
THAN THE FIRST AMENDMENT OR THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT, SO WE SHOULD
JEALOUSLY GUARD AGAINST THESE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS BEING
STRIPPED AWAY BASED UPON SOME
SORT OF PRETEXT.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO ABUSE YOUR
RIGHTS, THE SOLUTION IS NOT TO
TAKE AWAY MY RIGHTS.
>> AND WANT TO GET YOU IN ON
THIS BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IT'S A
HOT TOPIC.
WE HAVE THESE HORRIFIC SHOOTING
AND PEOPLE WANT TO END THEIR
SHOOTINGS.
THEY WANT TO PROTECT INNOCENT
LIFE WHICH IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT GOAL FOR ALL AMERICANS
.
ON THIS ISSUE OF THE 94 BAND
WHICH THAT IS CITED OFTEN TIMES
BY DEMOCRATS.
I JUST LAID OUT IN THE ANGLE HO
THE UNIVERSITY STUDY THAT WAS
DONE TO REPORT TO THE DOJ
COULDN'T SAY THAT IT REALLY
RESULTED IN FEWER GUN DEATHS,
THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE ON
TELEVISION, ON MSNBC, JOYCE
VANCE SAID THIS.
>> YOU KNOW, WE HAD A BAN ON
MILITARY ASSAULT STYLE WEAPONS
IN THIS COUNTRY IN THE '90s
AND IT WAS SUCCESSFUL.
WHEN THAT MAN STOPPED BEING IN
EXISTENCE WITH THE PRESSURE OF
THE NRA AND OTHER GUN SUPPORTER
THAT FLOODED THE GUNS BACK INTO
THE COUNTRY.
>> WE LAID OUT HOW ONLY 7
PERCENT OF GUNS THEY CRIMES
ARE COMMITTED BY GUNS BOUGHT
FROM A LICENSED DEALER.
HAD USED WHERE THOSE WITH A
DESIRE FOR GOING BACK TO THE OL
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN?
>> CITING THAT UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA STUDY CONFIRMS
WHERE THEY ARE INSANE WE NEED T
HAVE A BUYBACK PROGRAM IN PLACE
BECAUSE THE WEAPONS WERE ALREAD
OUT THERE THE LARGE CAPACITY
MAGAZINES WERE ALREADY OUT THER
BANNING THE SALE DIDN'T STOP IT
IT WAS ALREADY IN CIRCULATION.
THE GREAT DEMOCRAT EXCUSE ME,
REPUBLICAN RONALD REAGAN SAID
THESE THINGS, I SUPPORT THIS
SPORTING RIFLES, I SUPPORT HOME
DEFENSE IS WHAT JOE BIDEN HAS
SAID AS WELL I'M WITH RONALD
REAGAN, FURTHERMORE, WE BOTH
WORKED FOR REAGAN.
I MUST HAVE MISSED THIS DID
RONALD REAGAN PUSH AN ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN DURING HIS EIGHT
YEARS?
HE AND I BOTH WORKED IN DOMESTI
POLICY AT THE WHITE HOUSE, I
DON'T REMEMBER THAT PERSONALLY.
BUT MAYBE YOU DO.
YOUR MEMBER THAT HAPPENING?
>> I CERTAINLY DON'T.
I WOULD LIKE HIM TO ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT MORE.
>> GO AHEAD.
I DON'T WANT THAT TO GO.
>> INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH.
HE JUST TREATED OUT THE VIDEO
OVER RONALD REAGAN SPEAKING
INSANE THOSE EXACT WORDS.
>> HE SUPPORTED THE BRADY BILL
AS WELL AFTER HIS PRESIDENCY.
SO HE CLEARLY SUPPORTED
REGULATION OF FIREARMS TO RATE
VARYING DEGREE.
A VARIETY OF REGULATIONS
ABSOLUTELY ARE SUPPORTED UNDER
OUR FIRST AMENDMENT AND OUR
CONSTITUTION.
IT IS TIME TO END THE MASS
SHOOTINGS.
THE KEY THING THAT IS CONSISTEN
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES THAT
SETS US APART FROM ALL OF THE
OTHER DEVELOPED WESTERN NATIONS
WHICH HAVE UNTIL HEALTH ISSUES,
VIOLENT VIDEO GAMES AND ALL THE
OTHER THINGS IT IS HIGH RATE OF
FIRE.
>> GUNS CAN BE MODIFIED FOR ITS
REAGAN SPEECH I THINK I NOW KNO
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, HE
WAS REFERRING TO MACHINE GUNS.
AND BETO DOESN'T KNOW HIS LINE
FROM HIS ELBOW ON THIS.
IT'S A FULLY AUTOMATIC WEAPON.
THAT IS NOT ALLOWED IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. OR ANY PLACE I
THE UNITED STATES.
THEY HAVE BEEN BANNED FOR 80
YEARS.
THIS IS THE THING THAT THE
GUN-CONTROL FOLKS DO GREAT I
LIKE ETHAN, BUT YOU ARE RIGHT,
THE DECISION DID SAY JUST A
SCHOOL WE HAD DID SAY IT DOESN'
MEAN THAT THERE CAN BE NO
REGULATIONS ON FIREARMS, AND I
THINK HE'S RIGHT ABOUT THAT, HE
WAS RIGHT ABOUT THAT IN THE
DECISION,  BUT YOU'RE MAKING IT
OUT LIKE HE SAID OH, ANY SEMI
AUTOMATIC WEAPON CAN BE BANNED
AND REMAIN CONSTITUTIONAL, THAT
IS NOT NECESSARILY THE CASE AT
ALL.
THESE ARE IMPORTANT DETAILS THA
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE VERY CLEA
ON.
>> NUMBER ONE, THERE OBVIOUSLY
AS WITH THE SECOND AMENDMENT,
THERE ARE EXTREME CASES IN WHIC
ONE CAN REGULATE THE FIRST
AMENDMENT OR EVEN THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT.
YOU CAN'T SHOUT A FIRE IN A
CROWDED THEATER.
THERE IS A HEAVY BURDEN OF PROO
FOR THOSE WHO WOULD WANT TO
INFRINGE THE FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT.
NUMBER TWO, LEAPS EVEN AROUND
THE WORLD TODAY CASES WHERE THE
CONFISCATION AND EVEN BUYBACK
PROGRAMS HUGO CHAVEZ HAD A
BUYBACK PROGRAM FOR GUNS IN
VENEZUELA.
AS SOON AS THEY WERE DEPRIVED O
THEIR GUNS HE HAD STATE LICENSE
THUGS ON THE STREETS TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE INTO YOUR APARTMENT,
TAKE YOUR STUFF, WHY?
HE HAD DISARMED THE CITIZENS IN
PREPARATION FOR THAT.
THIRD, YOU FOCUS ON MASS
SHOOTINGS, MASS SHOOTINGS ARE A
LITTLE BIT OF AN ANOMALY WHEREA
THERE ARE EVERY DAY SHOOTINGS
OCCURRING IN EVERY MAJOR CITY I
THIS COUNTRY.
ITS ODD THAT THOSE DON'T LEAD T
DEMANDS FOR GUN CONTROL IN FACT
THOSE DON'T LEAD TO DEMANDS FOR
ANYTHING.
IT SEEMS ONLY WHEN THERE IS
SUDDENLY PEOPLE GO LET'S
CONFISCATE THE GUNS OF EVERYBOD
IN AMERICA BECAUSE EVERYBODY
WITH AN ASSAULT RIFLE POSES A
THREAT.
KNOW, EVERYONE WITH AN ASSAULT
RIFLE DOES NOT POSE A THREAT TO
THESE GUYS POSE A THREAT LET'S
IDENTIFY THE THREATS, FIND OUT
HOW WE CAN PREEMPT IT AND DEAL
WITH IT IN A TAILORED AND
NARROWLY FOCUSED WAY.
>> ETHAN, DO YOU THINK THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY, HAPPEN THEY
REALLY HAVE SHIFTED ON A WHOLE
BUNCH OF ISSUES.
THERE WASN'T GOING TO BE
HEALTHCARE FOR ILLEGALS, NOW IT
IS.
THEY WEREN'T FOR GOING IN AND
TAKING GUNS, BUT NOW THEY PRETT
MUCH ARE.
AWAY CERTAIN WEAPONS.
ON ISSUE OF THE OPEN BORDERS, I
SHOULDN'T BE A CRIME, THEY
SHOULDN'T BE PENALTIES EXCEPT
MAY BE A CIVIL DEAL.
SO THEY'VE MOVED ON A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES THAT THEY'D WAVED
OFF AS STEREOTYPE SPREAD.
>> THERE IS SOME TRUTH IN WHAT
YOU JUST HAD.
THERE IS A REALIZATION THAT WE
NEED TO BE STRONGER ON SOME OF
THESE ISSUES.
THE REALIZATION THAT THESE
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE PROPER
DOCUMENTATION LIVED AND WORKED
AMONGST US, RONALD REAGAN SIGNE
A BILL IN 1986 THAT REQUIRED
EMERGENCY ROOM TO ACCEPT THEM A
WELL.
I KEEP GOING BACK TO REAGAN.
HE SIGNED THAT LEGISLATION.
THE DEMOCRATS TODAY ACTUALLY
HAVE THAT UNCOMMON.
>> RONALD REAGAN WOULD NOT
RECOGNIZE THE CURRENT DEMOCRATI
PARTY.
HE WOULDN'T RECOGNIZE THE PARTY
TODAY.
I MEAN I DON'T LIKE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO AREN'T WITH US